welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and for the love
of all that is mr frundles we gotta talk
about the season six premiere of rick
and morty when we last saw our favorite
interdimensional duo evil morty blew the
central finite curve rick and morty
barely escaped before the citadel
collapsed and their entire supply of
portal fluid was painted drained and
destroyed we left these dudes floating
in space with nothing but each other and
a gaggle of [__] up traumatized mortys
but today we're finally facing the
consequences of the season five finale
and what it means for the smith sanchez
family lore i'm breaking down this
episode frame by frame to cover every
multiversal detail you might have missed
in season six episode one solaric let's
start with the episode title itself so
lyrics is a play on solaris a sci-fi
novel by stanislaw lem in the story the
main character discovers that the living
planet solaris can create beings out of
memories of the dead essentially clones
he's haunted by a replica of his late
wife which is similar to the ai rick
made to haunt himself with diane's voice
likewise the smith family is also faced
with their own past in the form of
familiar faces morty with his original
father jerry with his original family
and the baths with one another the
episode opens with a sea of bloated
bloody broken rick and morty's floating
around the destroyed citadel which
actually reminded me of the end of the
ritlanta's mixa when it's revealed that
evil morty has been discarding those
that opposed him by dumping their bodies
in space right outside the citadel now
those bodies don't just belong to select
ricks and mortys who stood in his way
evil morty's goal was to completely wipe
out the entire population of the citadel
and he's pretty much succeeded in an
extremely sarcastic homage to avengers
end game rick pulls a tony stark and
recaps their time aboard the escape pod
as he lay dying but obviously he doesn't
have iron man's text so he's using morty
to preserve his final observations just
as rick orders his cybernetic spine to
cook him up a surprise cocktail of
robitussin and death face beth swoops in
like captain marvel to save her dad and
son rick's drug synthesizing spine isn't
a new upgrade he's actually had it since
season four's dragon episode spinal cord
activate morphine in this season's intro
we get a bunch of cool new clips like
rick and summer flying through the air
to escape a very angry sugar glider
sherlock rick and holmes morty meeting
jack the ripper smiths with space bath
at a rick parade jerry doing his best
iron man impression in what looks like a
layer for space nazis and for some
reason melted butter morty and a skillet
of eggs once rick arrives safely back at
his garage his second priority is to
reboot the portal index immediately his
first priority is obviously to eat that
sandwich to prevent morty from suffering
from refeeding syndrome he has digested
bot reduced the meal into a safe
delicate little poop although rick
manages to restore their health he
accidentally resets all portal travelers
not all portal travel sending himself
morty and jerry back to their original
universes surprise remember back in
season 2's morty night run when rick
dropped jerry off at the jerry bree in
ferp rock plaza there was a mix-up when
they went to collect their jerry
resulting in a jerry from an alternate
multiverse coming home with r rick and
morty stranding season two jerry with
another family morty loses track of his
jerry claim ticket and ends up with a
blips and chicks ticket instead so when
another set of rick and morty's ask for
jerry's pickup number the confusion
causes the jerry's to be swapped so
basically we've spent the last four
seasons with a jerry of indeterminate
origins as the trio blinks green rick
tells summer to search for the protocol
to help them get back to this reality by
searching for the file titled booger
aids which she responds every file is
booger aids this is a call back to
season three's morty's mind blowers when
rick says this this better not have been
a good one what is this great booger
aids aids booger i gotta start using
real file names summer also finally
reveals to beth and space beth what
we've known since season one's rick
potion number nine that the rick and
morty they've been living with are not
their original versions their rick and
morty blew up after successfully solving
the cronenberg mutation so our pair fled
from their cronenberg universe to assume
the deceased's identities burying their
bodies in the backyard there's also the
chance that the rick and worry pair we
follow hopped to yet another reality
with similarly dead variants as the mind
blower memory of them fleeing
hyper-intelligent squirrels back in
season three suggests that they've
repeated this process at least once
after descending through the secret
tunnel in the garage floor summer
accesses a vending machine full of
superhero gear including coarse hammer
cyclops visor a green magneto helmet and
wolverine claws technically those are
more like x-23s claws but same five
there are also two purple cubes which
are likely rick's ultimate cubes back in
season four morty's palchachi gave their
life to get their hands on this
tesseract parody rick was disappointed
with the results hoping that this
ultimate cube would be a different color
than the one he already had if you're
full of chivalry and really want to
address someone as lord and lady
established titles can make it official
established titles is a project based on
a historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords and ladies in english they let
people buy as little as one square foot
of dedicated land so that they can call
themselves a lord or a lady in return
establish titles commits to planting a
tree it's a fun way to help preserve the
beautiful woodlands and biodiversity of
scotland while raising funds to support
global conservation efforts established
titles work with global charity trees
for the future and one tree planted to
help them plant a tree for every order
plus for those with scottish heritage
it's a great way to connect your family
roots your title pack gives you a
numbered plot of dedicated land on a
private estate in edelston scotland and
an official certificate with a crest you
can even change your name on credit
cards plane tickets and dating profiles
get a couple pack for you and your
partner with adjoining plots of land you
can literally have this gift ready in
five minutes here's a detail you missed
but this is phillips title i'm gonna get
my own because established titles told
me that the first 200 people purchasing
a title pack using our link will
effectively be next to each other within
a few minutes walking distance depending
on how many of you want to become a lord
or a lady we can build our little new
rock star's kingdom and since
established titles is extending their
labor day sale you can be a part of the
kingdom without emptying the treasury
take that phillip using code rock starts
to get an additional 10 off go to
establishedtitles.com rockstars to get
your gifts now while beth space beth and
summer head off to the ruins of the
citadel to loot some stuff and save
their family rick is transported back to
his universe of origin c137 which we saw
for the first time in season three's
rickshank redemption rick revealed an
altered memory of the day his wife and
daughter were killed by a rogue
multiversal version of himself but at
the end of season five's rick mariah
jack we learned that most of the details
he recalled about that day were true
everything in that universe is exactly
as rick left it literally as a cruel and
unusual form of self-torture he locked
this reality inside of timely forcing
everyone within it to relive the day
that diane and beth died over and over
unable to escape even in death due to a
drunken oversight everyone within the
loop still physically aged despite
experiencing a full-scale groundhog day
damn dude beth is 34 now that means that
this time loop has been going for
roughly 30 years he really used to drink
drink also real quick rick types in the
password to his liquor safe please note
that the numbers are 69 24 7.
on a somber note the wife hunting
program rick built is voiced by kari
walgren who also voiced diane in
previous episodes walgreen is also the
voice of rick's space cruiser and his
garage ai meaning rick has been using
diane's voice for his devices throughout
the whole series this iteration of
digital diane is particularly
heart-wrenching as it's designed to
always be calling to rick from the next
room in the house making the memory of
diane ever-present but comfort just
always out of reach heartbreakingly you
can see beth's childhood drawings of
horses pinned to the fridge as rick
grabs a drink back in the garage rick's
already rebuilt himself a souped-up new
ship before leaving he tells diane's
haunting bot that even though he doesn't
want to move on he has to meanwhile
morty land back on the cronenberg world
he originally came from where he and
rick c137 live together with the rest of
our morty's season one family for most
of the series morty incorrectly assumed
that he and rick were both from c-137
even identifying himself as morty c137
in the rickshank redemption actually if
you go back and watch that scene you'll
notice that the two ricks he's speaking
with give each other a surprised look
when he states his multiverse of origin
turns out that it's because these ricks
and likely others know that morty c137
doesn't exist beth c-137 died when she
was a young child long before she was
able to grow up point jerry and give
birth to summer and morty entering his
former home morty calls out to his og
family apologizing for last time of
course he's referring to the fact that
during their last encounter in the
rickshank redemption the council of rick
throws hunger games summer jerry and
beth stopping them from attacking summer
and morty morty follows a cloud of smoke
to his original dad's campsite where we
last saw summer reenacting the movie
jaws for her parents in the post-credits
scene of rick potion number nine morty
enters a convenience store where he
finds a bunch of cool porno magazines
like oily body boat women breeders
digest rolling boner pool hustler yummy
shapes vava bloomberg horny cars and sex
squire his dad walks up on him just as
he begins to investigate sex vogue and
takes him home where he reveals that
morty's original mom and sister are dead
summer didn't make it through the
de-thawing process and beth got sick in
a world without doctors in his grief
jerry found himself a barnes noble
reading books like the four agreements
by don michael ruiz beat pray love by
elizabeth gilbert and frank miller's the
dark knight returns to reach
self-actualization ultimately despite
his incredibly dark circumstances this
is the most functional jerry we've ever
met not only did he beat the apocalypse
as morty points out he also finally
achieved true happiness with his wife
and daughter that is before morty
brought dudes with ice guns to their
home because this jerry has suffered
great loss and has been forced to
rebuild a life for himself in a world
overrun by cronenberg monsters he's
developed some level of self-respect
that other jerry variants definitely
have not but this newfound confidence in
his own ability coupled with the tragic
deaths of his wife and daughter at the
hands of his son and father-in-law leads
him to hating morty he decides to bail
on him as soon as morty leaves the room
to grab downbeat the board game the
family played in previous episodes like
season three's rickmancing the stone and
season four's rattlestar raglactica fun
fact downbeat is the screenwriting term
for the beat happening at the beginning
of a scene that occurs before the
purpose of the scene begins usually when
we see these guys playing downbeat on
the show it's a quick little downbeat at
the beginning of a scene that almost
immediately goes in another direction
jerry steals morty's [__] and splits
when his son finally catches up to him
he angrily scolds him for ruining his
life killing his mom and sister and
bailing on his original family like
rick's choice to move on from the
constant torment of diane's memory this
jerry decides to move on from the life
he once knew leaving his son behind and
returning to the inner happiness that he
and the original family found all the
way back in season one after skirting
the consequences of destroying his
original universe for five and a half
seasons morty finally has to sit with
his guilt after rick finds morty in the
cronenberg dimension he reveals that r
morty's original grandfather was the man
who murdered beth and diane c-137 in the
inside the episode featurette it's
revealed that this rick is called rick
prime with prime in his title he just
might be the first rick to invent
dimensional time travel after rick prime
abandoned beth rick c137 eventually took
his place in morty's original reality in
hindsight it makes total sense beth's
abandonment issues don't come from our
rick rick c137 was as he put it himself
a different kind of rick the kind of
rick who loved his wife and daughter
even more than science itself the
jackass who left his daughter is the
same a-hole who robbed rick of a
lifetime of memories with his own diane
and beth after the council of ricks puts
an end to his homicidal reign of terror
our rick moves into rick prime's house
when rick finally tracks down rick prime
he and morty land on his invisible ship
which uncloaks itself to reveal a sphere
full of impossible devices via a
pre-recorded message on screen rick
prime taunts c137 with a naked rick that
he claims could either be the real him
or a dancing clone he refers to himself
as a little kaiser sose aka kevin
spacey's character in the usual suspects
whose legendary status as a crime lord
was shrouded in ethos not unlike rick
prime writer christopher macquarie named
this film character after the turkish
idiom soze bagma which means to drown
someone in words or to talk
unnecessarily and cause confusion which
is exactly what this killer rick is
doing in this scene visually rick
prime's lair employs the use of several
force perspective illusions adding to
the sense that nothing is as it seems
when rick makes a move to follow the
nudie rick morty warns him that it's
probably a trap and even tries to throw
himself down the shaft ahead of him
although rick tells him that his
knee-jerk borderline suicidal tendencies
definitely come from his original
grandpa morty replies that rick c137 is
his real grandpa family doesn't have to
be biological or even from the same
dimension family is who you choose to
love and show up for like rick has shown
up for our morty our bath our summer our
space beth and even very reluctantly for
our jerry time and again family is also
who you can share a cold corona with at
the end of a high speed chase with your
close personal pal dominic goretto but
that's just my opinion
not bad and when morty says the classic
phrase that ended the pilot episode of
the show 100 years rick and morty you
can feel how much he means it for a show
with giant incest space babies and
mermaid puss and turbulent juice
sometimes it really hits you on the
feels and this was one of those times
for me just as space beth beth and
summer have paused their sitcom fight
and are ready to take out the final boss
space squiddy rick and morty crashly in
at the citadel to pick them up
interestingly we learned that rick
performs child proofing modifications on
morty while he sleeps so that his body
is acclimated to space without need for
a helmet or suit does this mean that our
morty has cybernetic parts like his
grandpa for a guy who says he doesn't
like iron man this sure feels like the
training wheels protocol from spider-man
homecoming to me the gang rescues jerry
from a world that's exactly like season
two of rick and morty a world where
jerry and beth never divorced and were
forced to reevaluate their love for one
another but back in the family's current
home world season 2 jerry i.e the jerry
r jerry swapped with during the portal
reset accidentally releases mr frendles
mr rundles bites and infects the entire
planet with its consciousness in a
matter of seconds this apocalyptic event
is a bio-organic version of the grey
goose scenario coined by nanotech
engineer k eric drexler a grey goo
apocalypse is when a self-replicating
nanobot spreads across the globe by
converting all biomass into nanobots
luckily our family escapes but rick is
forced to find another uninhabited world
for them to live in just like before
this time they land in a reality where
all of them including space beth died a
horrific violent death of natural causes
in their living room just like back in
rick potion number nine everyone is
responsible for burying and carrying
their own rotting corpse the post-credit
scene reveals that back in the dimension
that got cronenberg the naked decoy rick
from the sawtrap really was rick prime
as we see him putting on clothes after
messing with a guy he approaches
original jerry who offers to team up
with him but rick turns him down jerry
slashes rick's throat declaring fatality
a reference to mortal kombat rick is
somehow able to instantly heal his wound
a feat that not even our rick can
accomplish rex body modifications do
save his life pretty frequently but i've
never seen him heal himself without any
outside equipment even when our rick and
morty initially returned to their
family's dimension rick needed the help
of a complicated scientific contraption
to return himself and mori back to
normal this rick appears to have actual
super powers which rex c137 is gonna
absolutely
follow me on instagram and twitter at
whitneypuppy follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you